okay but no have you actually tried dating
because I sometimes don't understand why these men think that
it's so they could invite you back to their place
you go back to their place and you're like sir
how have you washed your ass ever
there's not a drop of soap in this place
I know you're not using that joy dishwashing liquid to wash your hands
your ass and your dishes
but usually that's the only fucking soap you'll find
that orange shit
not even the cadon
usually they don't have shit up on their walls
they think you're gonna be that distracted by the
that you're gonna like
it's a bit of a shit show out there
I'm glad I found a real one a good one so far
keep you know what I mean
and and actually there's a lot of dudes that don't even have a place
and I don't mean they live with their mom
cause no shame in like
multi generational living
that's a thing it's real
it's valid and it's
it's beautiful and it's
you know the way the world is going right now
it makes a lot of sense for the multi generational living
if it's truly like a multi
generally generational living thing where he's contributing
and this is a big
you know a little home of family of people
generally speaking
they're homeless
and just trying to get with you because they want a place to stay
it's real quick
easy to spot them
they're gonna shower you with love and compliments
and fall in love with you really fast
and suddenly have some need to just stay your place for a couple days
or maybe they help you move and they just
like never leave
but somehow they're like a little fucking vampire and they watch on
and then they don't leave
so usually they're homeless
if they're not homeless
they have a place and it has
like a couch
one spoon and
like that's it
then mustard
maybe if you're lucky
so yeah I was very very
very impressed at my boyfriend's house when I went
and he's literally so
good luck out there
ladies good luck